et
fabien roussel va donc nous rejoindre
tout de suite alesi françoise dumont je
vous en prie on va laisser fabien
roussel faire son entrée et ses fans
dernier qui nous rejoint stéphane qui
dirige le bureau parisien du journal
ouest france bonjour stéphane et qui va
donc fait cette interview j'ai à mes
côtés puisque cet état via bien sûr en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale et fabien roussel on est en
direct merci beaucoup de nous avoir
rejoints tous les matins bonjour v
député du nord et secrétaire national du
parti communiste candidat à la
présidentielle et auteur de ce livre m'a
france heureuse solitaire et digne c'est
aux éditions du cherche midi on va
parler d'abord de cette crise des sous
marins soit bien russell emmanuel macron
et joe biden se sont donc entrepris hier
soir le président français le président
américain la france qui cherche à
français états unis qui cherchent à
apaiser les tensions la france qui est
va donc renvoyé son ambassadeur à
washington il avait été rapatrié il sera
envoyé à washington dès la semaine
prochaine est ce qu'un manuel macron à
raison de calmer les tensions
mais j'aurais préféré que le président
de la république fasse respecter la voix
de la france
est aujourd'hui la france n'est pas
respecté par son soi-disant allié les
états unis qui a mis un sérieux coup de
canif dans le contrat qui nous unit est
pas que le contrat de vente d'armes le
contrat diplomatique le contrat
politique qui unit deux pays qui quand
même ont une histoire commune
datant même d'avant la seconde guerre
mondiale
il y a là un acte unilatéral fait par
les états unis qui est extrêmement grave
et qui ne concerne pas seulement que ce
contrat d'armement les états unis est
une puissance nucléaire comme la nôtre
ils viennent de décider de transférer la
technologie de l'uranium enrichi un pays
l'australie dans cette zone au lit
existe déjà beaucoup de tension jamais
une puissance nucléaire ne s'était
permis cela jamais pas même la france
c'est donc un acte grave dans la course
à la maîtrise de cette technologie
nucléaire pour l'armement
et c'est pour ça que nous devons et
hausser le ton et c'est pour ça que tu
allais par envahir notre ambassade à
rabat son talent pour vous mais je pense
que notre président de la république
pêche par naïveté nous allons nous
risquons de rester alignés derrière les
etats-unis dans ses visées guerrières
voir impérialistes quand je vois que à
peine à vos après avoir quitté
l'afghanistan dans des conditions
désastreuses ils font choix aujourd'hui
de la tension militaire de l' escalade
militaire dans la zone indo pacifique où
je répète la france avec la polynésie la
nouvelle calédonie et les ressortissants
qui habite dans cette zone c'est presse
près de 2 millions de nos concitoyens
qui vivent là bas nous sommes là le pays
qui a la une influence maritime la plus
importante par nos territoires mais on
est carrément écartées méprisés c'est
grave grave c'est pour ça que j'ai
proposé mois comme mesures fortes de
sortir du commandement militaire intégré
de l'otan que sarkozy nous avait fait
réintégrer en 2009 il faut revenir à la
période d'avant et ne plus être alignés
derrière la politique des états unis sa
soeur était la meilleure façon de faire
entendre la voix de la france pour
reprendre votre expression de sortir du
commandement intégré de l'otan oui parce
que je pense qu'il ya deux choses il ya
besoin de retrouver notre indépendance
la liberté de pouvoir nous exprimer ça
c'est une chose mais l'autre chose très
importante c'est pas de retrouver cette
liberté pour dire n'importe quoi mais
retrouver cette liberté pour exprimer la
voix de la paix pour exprimer la voix
d'un pays qui est une puissance
importante qui siège au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu et qui a toujours eu
une voix originale dans notre histoire
et qui doit pouvoir faire entendre la
voix de la paix qui aujourd'hui n'est
plus portée il il faut retrouver un pays
la france qui doit dire c'est à l'onu de
régler les conflits de régler les
conflits pour éviter de rentrer dans des
conflits militaires pour trouver des
solutions politiques au conflit de ce
monde et donc nous devons retrouver
notre indépendance nationale pour porter
cette voie de la paix de la résolution
des conflits par la voie politique et
diplomatique ce qu'est ce qu'on peut
encore faire confiance aux américains
aujourd'hui et vous parlez de la voie de
la paix je vous rappelle la locution
latine si vis pacem para bellum si tu
veux la paix prépare la guerre est ce
qu'on n'a pas intérêt aussi à développer
une armée européenne
est ce que vous seriez favorable à ce
genre de choses mais tout dépend ce que
l'on met derrière une armée européenne
justement nous considérons nous que en
matière de politique de défense
nationale et européenne
nous avons besoin de coopération entre
nos pays européens et de travailler
ensemble mais plus avec les américains
mais d'être libre de la technologie
américaine parce que d'être intégré dans
le commandement militaire de l'otan nous
fait dépendre aussi entièrement de ces
technologies nous n'avons même plus la
maîtrise de ces technologies mais pour
faire décoller les drones que nous
produisons en europe nous sommes
dépendants de la technologie américaine
ils ne peuvent pas décoller ne peuvent
pas tirer sans l'appui et l'accord des
américains c'est un truc de dingue on
n'est même pas mettre de ça on n'est
même pas mettre de ça donc ça ne veut
pas dire se fâcher avec les états unis
ça veut dire retrouver son autonomie est
ce que ça veut dire que les manuels
macron aujourd'hui il est trop faible
face aux etats-unis est-ce que pour vous
il ne défend pas suffisamment la france
il fait preuve d'une extrême naïveté et
il fait le choix que la france reste un
pays alignés derrière les etats unis or
quand on voit la politique des états
unis et la politique étrangère
aujourd'hui bon nombre de commentateurs
pas seulement moi reconnaissent que
byden s'inscrit dans les pas de trump
sce america first ils n'ont pas d'alliés
love seul allié c'est leur intérêt
stratégique
ils ne répondent qu'à leurs intérêts
stratégiques il faut voir la manière
dont laquelle ils sont partis de
l'afghanistan à se demander et moi je
m'interroge je pose la question si cette
sortie de l'afghanistan n'est pas aussi
calculer et
provoquer pour créer une zone de
tensions à la frontière de la chine je
vous rappelle contre l'afghanistan et la
chine ya 80 km de frontière commune qui
touche cette zone
le
volonté délibérée des états unis et de
créer des tensions il ya une volonté
délibérée des états unis assumer
politiquement
d'affronter la chine d'être dans une une
politique de confrontation de tension la
ministre paris que j'ai interrogés hier
à l'assemblée nationale parle de risque
de guerre fin c'est pas moi qui le dit
tout le monde a bien conscience que
cette stratégie de la tension de la
confrontation peut conduire à des
risques de guerre tout doit être fait
pour apaiser ces tensions et la france
doit jouer ce rôle elle ne pourra pas le
faire si on ne s'émancipe pas des états
unis et notamment si on ne quitte pas le
commandement militaire ces derniers mois
je remarque depuis que j'ai annoncé cela
est bien maintenant une semaine d'autres
voient en france le réclame notamment à
droite pour vous dire qu'il peut y avoir
un consensus large dans notre pays pour
dire que la france doit retrouver une
voix nationale mais surtout une voie
pacifique un dernier mot compte tenu du
contexte est la gravité de cette crise
est ce qu'un manuel mâcon devrait
s'adresser aux français pour vous vous
attendez la parole du chef de l'état on
entend vos conférences par lyon entend
beaucoup jean yves le drian n'a pas
entendu emmanuel macron il doit parler
pour vous oui oui il doit parler il doit
s'exprimer parce que les affaires
internationales
sont des affaires extrêmement grave la
france n'est pas un petit pays enfin je
veux dire on fait partie des cinq
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité
nous sommes une puissance nucléaire nous
sommes trop alignées derrière les états
unis il doit s'exprimer et dire le rôle
que la france entend jouer dans les
semaines dans les mois qui viennent
parce que dans cette confrontation entre
les etats-unis et la chine
la france dans tous les cas de figure
sera perdante si on ne se fait pas
respecter si on ne se fait pas entendre
on va parler d'un sujet de la crise
sanitaire stade oui le gouvernement a
annoncé que finalement les choses
allaient plutôt pas mal on s'attendait
éventuellement une levée du pass
sanitaire sais pas ce qui s'est passé
hier c'est pas ce qui a été annoncé est
ce qu'il faut le maintenir ce pass
sanitaire qu'elle est
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement l'exécutif a raison dans la
gestion de la crise d'abord il faut
écouter ce qui se passe sur le terrain
et j'ai pris soin moi ce week-end en
rentrant dans ma circonscription à
saint-amand-les-eaux dans les villages
de de chez moi d'interroger quelques
commerçants des cafetiers des
restaurateurs ils disent eux que le pass
sanitaires s'il a été globalement bien
acceptée par les gens jeudi globalement
il a provoqué chez eux une perte de
clients quand même une importante de
champ intérieur qu est-ce qui vous
disent dans quelle proportion au dans
des proportions plus ou moins importante
mais il pleut ils disent
voilà ça ça lui irait fait ça nous a
fait du mal alors je dirais moi donc que
si ce choix qui a été fait par le
président de la république a conduit
aujourd'hui à ce que 50 millions de nos
concitoyens est au moins reçu une dose
et il ya encore du progrès pour
atteindre les 57 millions d'éligibles
aux vaccins
il faut maintenant pouvoir sortir du
pass sanitaire élargi aux zones de la la
vie quotidienne c'est bon là aujourd'hui
c'est au restaurant café oui oui il faut
les libérer libérons voilà il ya un
appétit à pouvoir revivre à pouvoir
consommer de nouveau de réinjecter de
l'argent dans le moteur de l'économie il
faudra pour ça aussi augmenter les
retraites et les salaires on y reviendra
mais en tout cas le vont ces contraintes
à et ses barrières là il ya un enjeu qui
est beaucoup plus important c'est
d'aller convaincre les sept millions de
nos concitoyens qui ne sont pas vaccinés
et qui ne sont pas des anti vaccins et
j'en connais autour de moi ils sont en
fait les du soin qui sont parfois
reclus dans la solitude de leur maison
de leur appartement fait pour aller
convaincre les sénateurs socialistes
avaient proposé la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous ça sera en débat
au sénat vous êtes favorable nous avons
mis nous notre proposition soit la table
il y a besoin de pouvoir travailler avec
ceux qui sont au plus près de la
population de ce2 de ceux qui les
connaissent qu'ils sont éloignés des
soins et les médecins de famille les
infirmiers et les infirmières des villes
et des villages ils les connaissent les
élus locaux les connaissent le maire
d'un village les élus
reconnaissent les dix quinze vingt
habitants de leurs communes qui ne sont
pas vaccinés et ceux qui ont la liste de
ces personnes là c'est la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie je demande
pas qu'il faut faire partager ces listes
et puis que tout le monde est menée
dessus mais à partir de c2c disent que
la caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
ah je propose que ville par ville ville
par ville département par département
avec la communauté médicale locale et
les élus locaux
à bien vous n'avez chercher un par un
ces personnes pour qu'elles soient
vaccinées c'est à dire en
laboratoire on va les chercher et je
suis moi pour la vaccination généralisée
c'est à dire que à terme nous soyons
tous vaccinés et j'ai pris position très
clairement au début de l'été pour
appeler la population à se vacciner et
je dis encore une fois qu'il faut avoir
confiance dans la recherche et dans la
médecine le vaccin représente un progrès
un progrès pour nous pour lutter contre
cette maladie il faut avoir confiance
dans ce vaccin un dernier mot vous avez
les retours de salariés suspendues du
fait de l'absence de passe vous êtes
interpellé là dessus je n'ai pas hésité
à interpeller directement
j'ai lu j'ai entendu et ça concerne 3000
soignant pour le coup
je serais moi plutôt d'avis à ne pas les
suspendre de leurs salaires et à leur
imposer une telle mesure trouvons les
moyens que ces salariés ne soient pas
mis en contact avec des personnes
malades à soigner et qu'il soit mis dans
d'autres services le temps que la raison
l'emporté et qu'ils se fassent vacciner
mais cette mesure de
licenciement déguisé n'est pas juste ce
n'est pas juste ça fait quand même bon
je sais que c'est un film ces trois
mines sur en tout un peu plus de 2
millions concernés et donc très
largement les soignants sont vaccinés
j'aurais préféré que l'on est une mesure
d' obligation vaccinale
pour plus de profession on a stigmatisé
les soignants alors qu'ils ont affrontée
cette pandémie avec courage les joueurs
en mettant leur vie en danger pour
certains mots qu'il fallait la rendre
obligatoire courageux travaillant dans
des conditions indignes sans masque avec
des sacs poubelles sur eux enfin est
aujourd'hui pour qu'il cesse at war qui
leur tombe ce professeur il fallait la
rendre mi mai pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est
obligatoire chez les gendarmes et chez
les policiers d'ailleurs on sait pas ce
que les gendarmes et des militaires et
reçoivent un ordre craque et sont
vaccinés mais pourquoi pour les
soignants et pas les enseignants il y à
des incohérences qui suscite justement
de la colère et des tensions il aurait
fallu provoquer au cou au contraire de
l'adhésion générale et c'est pour ça que
on aurait dû élargir les professions et
avoir un temps peut-être un peu plus
long pour se conformer à cette
obligation est justement le temps file
alors j'imagine que vous lavez épluchez
comme tout le monde subissent eux ce
dernier budget du quinquennat alors on
aimerait voir votre explication de texte
est ce que c'est un budget politique
avec plein d'argent magique de dents ou
est-ce qu'il est adapté à la situation
il est pas du tout adaptée à la
situation donc c'est un budget politique
avec plein d'argent magique de doivent
l'argent magique la droite veut dire ouh
là
le gouvernement laisse filer les
déficits publics
évoqué ce que moi je vois que le
gouvernement continue d'ouvrir le
robinet de la dépense publique pour
favoriser ceux qui n'en ont pas besoin
il va continuer de baisser l'impôt des
multinationales en réduisant le taux
d'imposition sur les sociétés de ces
grandes multinationales à 25% ces mêmes
multinationales qui distribue qui ont
distribué 60 milliards d'euros de
dividendes là en pleine pandémie il n'y
a pas de saison est moyen non mais elles
ont les moyens de payer des impôts enfin
excusez moi on est en train de siphonner
les caisses de l'état on cherche des
sous pour répondre aux besoins déjà
on va siphonner les caisses de l'état en
faisant des cadeaux à ceux qui n'en ont
pas besoin et donc le compte le
gouvernement continue à verser des
dizaines de milliards d'euros publics au
capital aux multinationales alors que
nous nous proposons d'élargir d'agrandir
le budget de l'état pour répondre aux
besoins des gens je fais une proposition
trouveront le moyen de baisser de
diviser par deux les factures
d'électricité
je demande une chose président de la
république tout de suite ça il peut le
mettre en oeuvre tout de suite bloqués
les prix bloquer les prix de l'énergie
de l'électricité et du gaz je demande à
ce qu à partir du 1er octobre il n'y a
plus une seule hausse
d'électricité et de gaz parce que selon
les prévisions ça va continuer à
augmenter en nous annonce 250 euros pour
2022 je demande à ce que ce soit bloquée
et ensuite moi en tant que candidat et
en tant que président futur président de
la république moi je propose de diviser
par deux la facture d'électricité et de
gaz comment est ce possible
on nationalise edf on retrouve la
maîtrise de cette merveilleuse outil de
production de distribution d'électricité
les taxes les taxes que prélève l'état
représentent 40 % sur la facture
d'électricité en enlevant ses taxes des
gens gagnent 40 % sur le coût de la
facture et ensuite si nous avons
nationalisée si nous retrouvons la
maîtrise cette production d'électricité
nous fixerons le tarif et nous
refuserons d'aller se mettre à table à
bruxelles avec ceux qui veulent à tout
prix libéraliser notre électricité il
faut retrouver la souveraineté dans nos
choix énergétiques et donc diviser la
facture d'électricité par deux c'est
possible mais la première chose à faire
est ça le gouvernement doit le faire
maintenant c'est de dire stop on arrête
on augmente plus les factures
d'électricité et de gaz j'espère que le
gouvernement entendra et j'ai pris à
partir du 1er octobre on a bien compris
votre demande on va parler politique oui
mais fabien roussel alors votre primaire
voulez mais comment ouverte semi ouverte
ou fermée je voudrais savoir ce que vous
pensez de ce qui se passe chez les
républicains les verts les socialistes
moi j'ai pas pour habitude de m'occuper
des affaires des autres c'est leur choix
ils ont leurs méthodes etc moi j'ai fait
le choix de
me présenter à la présidence de la
république c'était le 9 mai dernier que
nous avons annoncé cela je propose un
pacte avec les français pour la france
je propose de conclure avec eux un pacte
de progrès pour mettre au coeur de cette
élection présidentielle et des mesures à
prendre la question du pouvoir d'achat
des salaires et des retraites c'est pour
moi une question importante primordial
je ne supporte pas que dans mon pays on
puisse travailler même à temps plein
mais avec un salaire tellement bas que
l'on n'arrive pas en vivre dignement il
faut respecter le monde du travail et je
pense que c'est aussi la condition de
relancer l'activité du pays de relents
de redresser notre pays en permettant
aux gens d'avoir un salaire correct en
baissant les factures comme je vais
proposer nous allons redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux français qui vont de nouveau
consommer et remettre de l'essence dans
le moteur de l'économie il faut
retrouver ce cirque le vertueux d'une
croissance non pas des dividendes des
actionnaires mais celle de l'activité
pour ce que vous soyez mr ce local dans
ça il faut que vous soyez lui fabien
roussel alors on se parlait à sept
candidats à gauche il a quand même la
quasi-certitude d'être absent du second
tour est ce que quoi qu'il arrive vous
irez jusqu'au bout ou est ce que vous
dites mais il va falloir qu'on salle il
va falloir qu'on fasse une candidature
commune mais je devrai prêt à renoncer
vous sens l'intérêt de la gauche ou pas
enfin comment vous pouvez imaginer que
quand on se présente à une élection
présidentielle avec un projet et un
programme on puisse y aller en ayant la
moindre idée qu'à un moment donné on se
retirerait en décevant toutes celles et
ceux qui nous soutiennent toutes celles
et ceux qui demandent à défendre les
idées que je viens de proposer enfin si
je ne suis pas là qui va défendre sa
selle production d'énergie que je
souhaite décarbonés et la moins chère
possible qui va défendre la hausse des
salaires et des retraites et je propose
là aussi qu'il y ait tout de suite une
hausse des retraites pour nos plus
petits retraités je demande la
suppression de la csg sur les pensions
ça c'est un amendement dans le cadre du
du projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
avec un jour d'hui mais j'ai toujours
discuter avec l'ensemble des forces de
gauche et pas que d'ailleurs il ya un
dialogue entre responsables politiques
qui ça rien à redire qu'il arrive
ça d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs mais oui il
y a une volonté pour moi
d'accéder à la présidence de la
république de passer ce pacte avec les
français et de faire événement les
français je vous le dis quand même hein
parce que les sondages et de dire et
vous serez pas et vous serez pas
président attention les français
n'aiment pas qu'on leur dise
qui sera élu et comment ils aiment bien
faire événement il aime bien choisir
alors laissé leur ce choix-là et vos
masques on a parlé descendait le grand
ce le grand moment du débat va arriver
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent et donc laisser leur choisir la
présidentielle quoi qu'il en coûte mais
pour les législatives vous avez commencé
à discuter avec vos petits camarades
j'allais y venir justement est donc cet
échange que nous avons avec l'ensemble
des forces de gauche justement je les
propose et j'ai lancé cet appel à
l'ensemble des forces de gauche
officialisée nous la rose a soumis par
la présidentielle et que des alliances
possibles il y à 577 il y à 577
circonscriptions et danser 577
circonscriptions il y à des situations
nouvelles issues des dernières élections
cantonales et régionales comment
faisons-nous que dans le plus possible
de ces circonscriptions des candidats de
gauche communistes
socialistes a soumis écologistes
l'emportent et regardons une par une ces
circonscriptions créons les conditions
de cette victoire l'élection
présidentielle et le moment d'un grand
débat où là nous devons nous avons une
responsabilité nous à gauche d'aller
chacun cherchait tous ces électeurs qui
n'y croient plus qu'ils sont déçus
qu'ils s'abstiennent ou parfois se
trompent de colère et vote à l'extrême
droite nous avons là un grand défi lors
de cette élection présidentielle d'aller
reconquérir ses choeurs et c'est ed et
al élections législatives héliades c'est
en fait ce sont des contes et des
situations complètement différente il ya
des circonscriptions où ce set sont des
députés de gauche qui sont sortants
communistes socialistes insoumis comment
on fait pour que demain nous créons
toutes les conditions de leur victoire
et comment on va aller anglais merci
beaucoup merci fabien roussel d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin on a bien
compris votre message merci stéphane on
regarde la une d'ouest france c'est le
budget est là une de ouest france ce
matin à sept mois de la présidentielle
un dernier budget des consignes et merci
beaucoup dépensiers merci stéphane
d'avoir été avec nous si fabien roussel
[Musique]